so uh I'm not sure if you're familiar
with them but Andrew yang is the
presidential candidate currently running
with the math in all capital letters and
his hats as a slogan Isis stands for
make America think hard okay
I'll vote for so and his name rhymes
with yours yang strang so but he also
loves math and he comes from that world
but he also looking at it makes me
realize that math science and
engineering are not really part of our
politics right litical discourse about
political a government in general yeah
what do you think that is well what are
your thoughts on that in general well
certainly somewhere in this system we
need people who are comfortable with
numbers comfortable with quantities you
know if you if you say this leads to
that they see it it's undeniable but
isn't it strange to you that we have
almost no I mean I'm pretty sure we have
no elected officials in Congress or
obviously the president yes that is
either it has an engineering degree or a
mess yeah well that's too bad you know
if you could a few who could make the
connection yeah it would have to be
people who are at the or who understand
engineering or science and at the same
time can make speeches and and lead yeah
and spire people yes yeah
you